no violence in kirkuk
it's the multi-ethnic cities residents
took to the streets Saturday could on
one side
Arabs and ethnic turkmen on the other
kirkuk about
265 kilometers north of Baghdad has long
been at the heart of dispute between
Iraq's semi-autonomous Kurdish region
and authorities in the capital
after Baghdad handed control of the
city's security headquarters to a
Kurdish political party Arab and turkmen
residents closed a road linking kirkuk
to the Kurdish Regional capital of erbil
a hundred kilometers to the north
Kurdish counter protesters followed and
by evening Athens curfew was in place
the Kurdistan Democratic party which
runs the Kurdish region has called on
the prime minister imbaghdad to
intervene directly to put an end to the
unrest
this incident comes at a critical time
while authorities in Baghdad and the
semi-autonomous Kurdish region engage in
talks to resolve several unsettled
issues including the federal budget a
dispute over oil exports and its arming
of anti-iran armored groups in the North
if the situation in kirkuk now gets out
of control it could add to Iraq's
already long list of political troubles
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera